There are a few topics that are considered
off-limits at my family’s Thanksgiving table,
and one of them is TAXES, or more specifically,
the American tax SYSTEM.
Virtually everyone has a strong opinion about
it: It’s unfair!
It doesn’t go far enough!
It’s too complicated!
Cable news and social media are filled with
passionate debates about it, but how many
people actually know how our current tax system
works?
If your eyes glaze over when you hear phrases
like “progressive taxation” and “marginal
brackets,” you’re not alone.
Even some of our law-makers seem to have a
shaky grip on the concept.
But if you hope to have a say in a system
that impacts your wallet every day, you should
understand how—and why—it ended up this
way.
Let’s start with something all of us can
agree on.
The U.S. tax code is complicated.
Really complicated.
It’s one of the most complicated systems
in the world, taking the average citizen 13
hours to file each year.
Compare that to, say, Japan, where it’s
closer to 15 minutes.
And one reason we have such a confusing system
is because our income is taxed at different
rates, depending on how much we earn.
For nearly 100 years, our country had no income
tax.
The first one was levied in 1861 during the
civil war at a flat 3% tax on income over
$800.The next year, in 1862, the first “progressive
tax bracket” appeared, with the 3% rate
AND a 5% rate for any income earned over $10,000.
Then in 1872, the income tax was repealed
because — get this — the government no
longer needed the money.
Can you even imagine…?
Then in 1913 with the 16th Amendment, progressive
taxes made a permanent come-back.
It gave the Federal government the free reign
to tax workers’ income in every state.
So what is a “progressive tax”?
Well, you can think of tax systems coming
in one of three main flavors.
Regressive, Proportional, or Progressive.
A regressive tax impacts lower paid workers
more severely.
Paying sales tax on groceries or clothing
will end up being a higher portion of a low-earner’s
pay check than a high-earner.
A worker earning $20,000 a year who pays $1,000
in sales tax will be parting with 5% of his income.
Another making $100,000 paying that same tax
for the same goods will only be charged 1%
of her income for the same thing.
A simpler solution would be a proportional
tax, where, simply put, everybody pays the
same percentage of their income, no matter
how much they make.
Nine states currently impose a proportional,
flat state income tax.
That means no matter how much you make, your
tax rate stays the same.
For example, 5% of every dollar earned.
Finally there’s the progressive tax, a system
that has a heavier impact on high earners.
Low earners may end up paying little or nothing,
with only the wealthiest people paying the
highest tax rates.
How does this actually work?
Through a series of different tax levels or
“marginal tax brackets”.
Buckle up, it’s about to get exciting!
Let’s say you’re a single person making
$60,000/yr.
A quick look at the IRS Tax Brackets will
tell you that you fall into the 22% bracket.
Do you have to give the government 22% of
your income?
No!
A common misconception is that entering a
higher tax bracket means your whole income
is taxed at the higher rate.
So how much are you actually paying?
After taking your available deductions, you’re
left with $47,800 in “Taxable income”.
As of 2019 we have 7 marginal tax brackets
between 10 and 37%.
Each bracket along the way applies to one
specific chunk of your income, not the whole thing.
Bracket 1 is for your first $9,525, and it
gets taxed at 10%.
Next stop is Bracket 2.
This applies to $29,175, and is taxed at a
rate of 12%.
Last stop is Bracket 3, where your remaining
income of $9,100 will be taxed at 22%.
Even though you’re in the 22% tax bracket,
your “effective tax rate” is only 10%,
thanks to the marginal rates in our progressive
tax system.
So a single-filer with a taxable income of
$500,001 may be in the highest tax-bracket
of 37%, but only $1.00 is taxed at that rate.
The effective rate will be much lower.
This system is definitely more complicated
than a flat-tax.
But is it fair?
Simply put; no.
A progressive tax system, by definition is
unfair.
It allows lower earners to pay very little
tax…
In fact more than 44% of Americans pay no
federal income taxes.
And the more money you make, the less of it
you will keep.
Opponents of progressive taxation tend to
be higher earners, arguing that the system
“punishes” wealthy people, and actively
discourages making a higher income.
They claim that a flat-tax would be simpler,
easier, and more fair.
Supporters of a progressive tax, however,
point to the real-world human impact on struggling
families and low wage earners.
They argue that if people have a greater ability
to pay, then they should pay more.
And a progressive tax system, they claim,
can counteract the regressive nature of sales
taxes, easing the impact of taxes on your
rent or groceries, while hitting you harder
in your ability to take vacations or buy luxury
goods.
And while nobody loves paying taxes, the average
US tax-payer actually pays less than almost
any other developed nation.
Compared to, say Belgium, we get off pretty
easy.
Their lowest tax-bracket is 25%, and the highest
is 50% for anything over 38,080 Euros!
Do you feel our progressive tax-system encourages
laziness?
Does it discourage people from earning more
money?
Or is it giving a leg-up to people with lower
salaries?
Whatever your opinion, now that you understand
the mechanics of marginal brackets and progressive
taxation, you’ll be in a much better place
to argue about it over your next Thanksgiving dinner.
Or in the comments section.
And that’s our two cents!
Thanks to our patrons for keeping Two Cents financially healthy.
Click the link the description if you'd like to support us on Patreon.
I’m sure you have an opinion about our current
tax system, go ahead and put it in the comments,
or you could share it with your elected representative!